you and i had an argument about you said  drake's not hip-hop no no no no and i  said listen drake makes hip-hop music  and you said well drake there's no  culture with drake i think drake makes  rap records  okay and i i understand the concept of  and and and the reason i really kind of  didn't even care about this conversation  no more is because i'd never thought of  it as a derogatory thing  like i never thought it was a derogatory  thing to to to classify things i don't  again i'm back to the same point of i  don't care how you want me to look at  you let's talk about the classification  of things so we have some sense of  things that we can share versus we  create in a world where everybody can be  anything they want i don't like that